owen what does this do to isil
well certainly weeks and weakens it
further
it has already been weakened over the
last two years three years
with sustained uh american western and
regional
um offensive against its uh
infrastructure uh over those large
swaths of lands
in iraq and syria and with the killing
of its leaders one of its more potent
leaders i must add
certainly the the islamic state as we've
known it
no longer exists probably a new
more like islamic state 2.0
is already emerging of course out of the
destruction
of its uh caliphate and that is one as
your report mentioned earlier would
probably look
more on the model of al-qaeda than on
the model of a caliphate where it just
takes control of a piece of land and
declares a regime
i think we're going to see more of an
islamic state that is
as they say in in in security studies
segmented polycentric ideologically
networked
groups meaning they will be separate
they will be diverse they will be
geographically in different areas
urban and non-urban and they will simply
declare
themselves to be that group they don't
have to be
hierarchically answering to
someone in specific place they could be
they're doing their own business
but they will be calling themselves
branding themselves as islamic state
very much as we've seen al qaeda do over
the last 20 years
which i guess would allow isil if
and when they make a resurgence if and
when big if of course
that would allow them to carry on with
their so-called war of attrition because
they're on record as saying that's what
we will do
but to go back to our baghdadi for a
second what was his
unique quality the way that he gave a
geographical location a physical
location
to the caliphate and nobody from his
ideology
had ever done that before
yes absolutely i think the whole idea is
that he's
the difference between him and al-qaeda
is exactly that
that he was ambitious and now some would
say reckless enough
to establish and qualify it when the
conditions were not
conducive for such a project in the
islamic world
al-qaeda always thought that this will
come at the end
this will not be at the beginning of
their you know grand
project for the islamic world but the
fact that
that baghdadi did do what he did out of
musa and then on to
large parts of syria and iraq looked
quite attractive in the beginning in
fact it did attract as your report said
thousands of fighters and families and
so on and so forth to it
but it's utter failure to actually run
anything that
looks even remotely like a decent place
like a successful place
let alone like a state and with the
offensive by
everyone everyone against them
leading to it's their destruction now
sends them back to the whole idea that
the whole point of it was actually wrong
and baghdadi was wrong
in that sort of an early establishment
of the caliphate
and as i said now everyone is going to
go back to the model of al-qaeda of that
score called spin model the segmented
polycentric network type group
and i think that will be also dangerous
perhaps even more dangerous
than what we've seen from the islamic
state although i must emphasize
those those millions who suffered from
the islamic state in iraq syria and
other parts of the middle east
of course are now relieved by the death
of baghdadi unfortunately
and while we spoke a lot and the united
states administration speaks a lot about
ideology in fact the root causes in the
region
are just as important perhaps i would
say more important than the aspects of
ideology
because al-qaeda and the islamic state
were born out of the destruction and war
in afghanistan
iraq and syria later on yemen and other
places
so the root causes the foreign invasions
of
an occupation the sectarianism
the russian-sponsored al-assad regime
the maliki-sponsored
regime by the united states and those
sorts of
horrific circumstances from afghanistan
to syria through iraq
that have led to the rise of al-qaeda
and later on to the rise of the islamic
state
unless those root causes are taken care
of
i think the ideology will continue to
flourish
what do you make of these comments
marwan that we've been getting from the
russian foreign ministry
ministry out of moscow they are they are
questioning and i quote the quote
validity of what donald trump has been
saying
well you know i think for me just sort
of first impression it sounds more like
public relations stunt on the part of
the russians who are actually
now looking and watching how the united
states had basically
assa you know led to the death of
baghdadi under their own noses meaning
under areas basically now
under the control of the russians
meaning in syria
uh but on but if we move beyond that
statement uh peter and i think that's
important strategically
to look at how trump of course thanked
the russians first
i think what's important here is that
the trump administration i think like
the obama administrations
think of the russians as the best
possible partner
in syria and in the war against terror
and why is that well because
it's another let's say superpower or was
a superpower
russia is the only country that's
involved in the middle east that has
good relations
with everyone in the middle east meaning
israelis and palestinians saudis and
iranians
turks and egyptians it's only putin it's
only a russia that has good relations
with everyone and
is getting more and more involved so for
the trump administration
russia is going to remain a very
important
let even i would say indispensable
partner to resolve all sorts of issues
notably in syria and in the war on
terror
so no matter what moscow might be saying
today because it lost face
basically to the trump administration
gaining or making gain against
al-baghdadi and the islamic state
i think in the long term you will see
more engagement by
the united states and russia to resolve
issues
they see themselves as the adults in the
room and that
most of the local partners are not
reliable and hence
they will be talking more to each other
about the future of syria and iraq and
the war on terror than before
okay marwan we'll talk to you in our
next hour in the meantime thanks very
much